a cab a bags barback so our eyes of
insanity I think wherever we just we
just completed a marshmallow
anyways that's day that's bad ice let's
think we have like half an hour left I
don't know I don't know okay oh no we
just fished marshmallow what's in here
nothing mana from motion sickness so
this is the motion inducing is insane
okay let's look let's look and then I
can what is that dr. Abraham thank you
so much for sending alfred Binet oh that
was Bedales which is application by
checking children IQ
I don't want jinx it but would connected
with increase in IQ very small children
okay so he found something pretty nice
okay something about increasing the
development of kids look in here
anything in here nothing never as what
is that yeah that's ways of time okay
that's gross okay
[Music]
anything here now I forgot slow this
thing is I don't like over a pin in this
room okay so that's what I'll be coming
back for
address thing
can I help you I left a tip that a flame
that's safe research theme the test of
the therapy increasing the intelligence
among children the subject of the
research theater towel the first
attempts to increase IQ I started using
suggestion and manipulation method
during REM sleep the subjects handled
the experiment very well I began the
observation and started the manual
visual tests phase okay what was that
noise so we just like thought it we're
not noise that's a little change okay
man let's think you really got a how
grande things like piss on the wall
why's it so dirty Jesus
yeah yeah that's again okay Lux barking
can I go in here
that's way too dark okay I'll be gone in
there I have that open well cut that out
yep
okay that is horrifying okay let's see
what's gonna scare me now now yep
check it on here there's an outpoint
it's way too quiet in this room I'm
gonna get the bejesus scared out of me
when I say bejesus I'm not talking about
a change that's talking about but Jesus
thank you thank you thank you
and cats luck luck nothing Oh long
hallway
you got that psychobabble you gonna make
it try not to get your panties Don okay
let's go let the help that's right
Claire it out okay
trying to get out of here
yeah a really good I work around this
power you know what this game is
actually more probably more scared for
electrical engineers being like wow like
what is going on here that must be very
scared relationship and all just kind of
tation order it's like you would inspect
the elevator or not you'll they have
like elevator certificates but you're
really scary okay yeah okay
got a happy ass in here and I'll what
the hell is I playing everything was
based on suggestion I thought it would
not harmful you might have an
interesting patient soon
holy God no leave that scared that gonna
make Wow
that was a good one that guy got me
actually oh great what how's that cut
that up yeah that's getting filthy in
here is this filthy what is that bird
man did I die oh okay I guess I got that
good ending I don't think I can go in
here right no it's like locked did he
cut this channel what something I don't
know or I'll cut that chain
see here anything in here it's so clean
it's also so outlet thank you thank you
for actually being good about lighting
okay okay
it's blocked over there I think so
they're making it easy for me yeah is it
getting darker place down why are there
always freakin flower petals gone from
yeah the old ocean
we got in there we gotta cut us huh yeah
wake up baby
yeah where you go oh my god how I go is
kind of my sky
I guess I am rising almost to insanity
hope we find out with that why that is
right whoa
how's that in this environment down
everywhere they can do indoor and
outdoor environments
hmm okay
what's on the ground grass
there's a sanding in the game not what I
really know is I guess there's no ending
the camp just goes on for like 20 years
anything on this bount I should still do
something here
[Music]
nice light I'll swing
Shroomish with teddy
[Music]
okay cuz that can sail away now
alright we're gonna end this episode
here guys hope you all enjoy it I hope
you'll enjoy a pretty quick ever said
but you know alright until next time
guys oh wait there's kiddin
I can't stop here
[Music]
it's beautiful
it's beautiful man everything goes slow
in this camp yeah that's right okay well
in this year thanks for watching y'all
thank ya